the family of a Chinese researcher who
vanished in Illinois is appealing to the
public for help today surveillance video
from June shows that ying-ying Jiang
getting into a black satin car on the
day that she disappeared investigators
believe that she is dead
the former graduate student Brent
Christianson has been charged with her
kidnapping Anna Werner spoke with
Jiang's family she is at the bus stop at
the University of Illinois where Jiang
was last seen alive and a good morning
good morning this bus stop behind me
this is the last place that Jiang was
seen alive that was over two months ago
her family has been waiting ever since
and they are heartbroken ying-ying
Jiang's mother sobbed throughout the
news conference where the family spoke
out for the first time since her
disappearance with each passing by day
the chances of finding a live decrease
Jiang's mother and brother arrived in
Illinois just a few days ago her
boyfriend Shaolin Ho says they all feel
helpless can you describe what this has
been like for the family for her mom and
dad woman every day is like torture for
us he says we live in agony every day 26
year old Jiang came from China to study
for her PhD at the University of
Illinois on June 9th surveillance
cameras captured her getting into this
black Saturn police say is owned by
Brent Christianson an FBI affidavit says
Christensen later admitted that he
offered jiang a ride and that she got in
his car but claims he let her out a few
blocks away the same affidavit also says
while under surveillance
he was recorded saying he brought jiang
back to his apartment and held her
against her will he faces one count of
kidnapping anthony bruno is one of
Christensen's defense attorneys our
client is presumed innocent his
presumption of innocence will remain
with him until this case is over Jiang's
family says they will stay until she is
found it is a Chinese tradition howe
says to be buried in your hometown
fallen leaves returns to its roots we
need to find her and take her home the
family has also sent a letter to
President Trump asking for
his help Christensen's trial is
scheduled to start in September but his
attorney says he'll be asking for a
delay in order to go through a large
amount of evidence provided by
prosecutors bill a lot of thanks